tell us about the importance of casting
actors for who they are as a person not
just strictly on acting ability but
actually that's on my theory that comes
from Nelly thin was a casting director
because
a lot of blood james cameron's titanic
terminator an elephant for Gus Van Sant
LA confidential Allison and she her
theory was not to cast actors for their
acting abilities but for who they are as
people which to me was revolutionary
because she said that when they are
tired are they run out of ideas so they
are stressed they will always go back to
who they we are at their core you know
as people and if you can figure that out
in the 15 minutes that you have with
them during the casting during the
audition then you kind of know know
which components you are putting
together you're putting a past together
up you know if there's like this group
of people this puzzle piece that you
putting together and you're not taking
the risk that you are otherwise tell you
where you are spending four weeks
together with them and they have to
spend four weeks together and if they if
turns out that they hate each other
after a week bo kind of screw because
you you won't be able to create
chemistry all that so you really have to
get to do they really are
and what I did with necessary death and
then later what the next movie too was
that on I'm putting myself into the
waiting room and I'm pretending to be
one of the actors waiting to go in and
the actors that are waiting they want to
prepare and they're in their zone so the
last thing they want is for person next
to them to go okay are you doing
interval and you really buy their
reaction to that by me getting on their
nerves you really can tell a lot already
of who they are how patient they are how
generous they are because there are
people that will be very rude and say
leave me alone you know and I already
know by the time that we walk mean that
I don't want to work with them because
they're they already don't have the
patience for that then they're not going
to applications from me as a director
and putting fellow actors and all that
you know sir and the other thing is that
I think actors always behave differently
once they know you are the director you
know so through the only five innocent
minutes that you ever get with them
before casting on where they don't know
that and you are very cool yes
valuable and with a lot of directors
that I talked to say the same thing that
they already have such a strong
impression of someone before they even
shake their hand for the first time that
they already basically know if they
would work with that person as a person
or not you know I don't know actors
actually know that how important that
first moment is if someone looks at you
while they shake your hand someone's
kind of trying to put on a show already
before they even should get about it um
especially with our our technique
because we didn't actually write out
scenes we didn't have written dialogue
we were improvising everything so I knew
that I needed people that were a little
bit more eloquent than the average guy
up the street and people that could
create a character concepts that were
basically the cold lighters you know so
you kind of look for different qualities
I think it's too
different skill sets you know people we
saw people that were great actors but
could not improvise to save their lives
and there were great people for us that
could really do an improv well I
couldn't bring lines to life it's like
two completely different things um and
because we knew we were just gonna
improvise we could completely
concentrate on
and then because we cast them the way
that Mellie film could have taught me to
cast them they really became this family
because our shoot wasn't it was supposed
to be two weeks but then turned out to
be three years you know so if they if
the chemistry between them had been as
solid as it was we would never have
survived those three years because
people just you know one of them would
quit or what I rent the whole thing
will fall so they really grew together
as this family and I think you feel that
a lot of what you feel in the film of
this group coming together is what
actually happened because we could
actually shoot in sequence which is a
huge benefit in
especially if you don't have a written
of emotional arc of every single
character was actually developed by them
I wasn't something that I was dictating
you know something that they did when
they were working on their character and
it became them you know if they were so
involved in the whole thing because they
were actually the lighters of the whole
thing so I think a lot of that passion
can carry us through the three years
you